in the year 1988 a series of puzzling
deaths grips the city of Philadelphia
multiple individuals experience
simultaneous hemorrhages resulting in
the disintegration of their brains and
massive blood loss police officer Thomas
Lockhart accompanied by his partner
Maddox and his brother-in-law detective
Holt embarks on an investigation to
unravel the perplexing case Lockhart's
Keen Eye detects a crucial connection
among the victims as he stumbles upon
similar puncture wounds on each lifeless
body the pieces start to come together
when Lockhart and Maddox come across an
assault victim who Bears the same
Tell-Tale wounds in her last moments the
dying woman describes her attacker as a
black woman with a wounded hand driven
by a sense of urgency Lockhart and
Maddox managed to locate the suspect
initiating a high-stakes Chase into the
depths of a subway system in a shocking
turn of events the suspect swiftly
subdues Maddox leaving Lockhart alone to
confront her to his bewilderment the
mysterious woman reveals astonishing
details about his life even foreseeing
that his wife is about to give birth
that very day tension reaches its peak
as the suspect predicts her own demise
moments before engaging in a struggle
with Lockhart the harrowing
confrontation concludes tragically when
a train hurtles towards them resulting
in the suspect's untimely death despite
the baffling nature of the case the
police reluctantly closed their
investigation haunted by the many
unanswered questions that linger in the
air meanwhile amidst the chaos Lockhart
faces an overwhelming personal loss as
his wife tragically passes away during
childbirth fast forward to the Year 1997
the city of Philadelphia finds itself a
victim to fear and uncertainty once
again a chilling Killing Spree is
underway but this time it appears to be
a disturbing copycat case detective
Lockhart determined to uncover the truth
is left puzzled and Desperately Seeking
answers balancing the demands of his
detective work and the responsibilities
of being a single father to his young
daughter Amy Lockhart faces a daunting
challenge with no apparent motives or
connections between the victims during a
time of turmoil and bewilderment
Lockhart's persistent pursuit of Justice
takes an unexpected turn a vital clue
emerges as he stumbles upon a set of
keys recovered from the crime scenes in
1988 leading him to an aircraft craft
manufactured in 1996 enter Naveen Rao a
physicist who boldly suggests that these
findings could be evidence of The
elusive concept of time travel however
Lockhart accompanied by his partner
Maddox dismisses Rao's extraordinary
Theory considering it implausible and
irrelevant to their ongoing
investigation motivated by his
unwavering determination to unravel the
truth Lockhart follows the trail to an
Airfield unaware of the astonishing
Revelation that awaits him to his sheer
disbelief he comes face to face with the
very same suspect from the 1988 case
seemingly Untouched by the passage of
time the encounter takes a chilling turn
resulting in maddox's tragic demise and
Lockhart becoming a hostage in the
clutches of this enigmatic individual
once again the suspect reveals intimate
knowledge about Lockhart's life defying
all logical explanations caught in a web
of bewildering circumstances Lockhart
finds himself grappling with the
unfathomable the mysterious suspect on
the verge of Disappearing offers him a
cryptic warning leaving him with more
questions than answers the boundaries of
what is possible blur as Lockhart
confronts the inexplicable and the
secrets of time into intertwine with his
very existence summoning him into a
realm of intrigue moving forward to the
Year 2006 we find detective Lockhart
transformed into a determined private
investigator consumed by an
all-encompassing obsession to solve the
perplexing case that has haunted him for
years his unwavering belief in the
involvement of time travel and the
enigmatic Dr Rao remains unshaken even
though the elusive doctor has vanished
Without a Trace meanwhile Lockhart's
daughter Amy now a teenager resides with
Detective Holt her caretaker the once
close bond between Lockhart and Amy has
dwindled reduced to sporadic
communication but Lockhart's Relentless
pursuit of the truth persists and he
discovers a previously unknown victim
from the chilling 1988 murders seeking
answers he visits the victim's wife only
to uncover a shocking Revelation her
late husband was involved in a white
nationalist militia group shedding new
light on the motives behind the killings
Lockhart fueled by his Newfound
information meets with Holt and puts
forth a daring Theory He suggests that
the suspect whom he believes to be
capable of moving back in time as they
move forward is automatically
eliminating members of these terrorist
groups however Holt dismisses the theory
insisting that Lockhart seeks
psychiatric help instead undeterred by
his partner's skepticism Lockhart takes
matters into his own hands stealing
Holt's badge Lockhart assumes the guise
of a police officer and embarks on a
daunting Mission he tracks down the
former girlfriend of the white
nationalist leader only to arrive at her
home to a gruesome sight the suspect has
claimed yet another victim Lockhart's
determination reaches its peak as he
relentlessly pursues The elusive culprit
in a gripping confrontation he manages
to wound her hand with a bullet before
she vanishes into a time machine leaving
Lockhart both exhilarated and
disoriented by this otherworldly
encounter as the dust settles Lockhart's
Pursuit comes to an abrupt halt as he
finds himself in handcuffs arrested by
none other than detective Holt little
does he know that an unseen figure Dr
Rao silently observes the scene his
intentions veiled in mystery the story
continues in the year 2015 and we find
Lockhart anxiously awaiting a meeting
with a woman on the beach as he waits a
voice message from his daughter Amy
plays requesting his presence at the
birth of her child just as Lockhart's
thoughts wander to his family an
unexpected turn of events unfolds in a
shocking twist Lockhart is suddenly
kidnapped by none other than Dr Rao The
elusive figure from his past Rao
confesses to being the Mastermind behind
the development of the technology used
by the woman to eliminate her victims
this technology involves an injection
that can be triggered remotely Through
Time causing fatal effects surprisingly
Rao reveals a change of heart claiming
to now believe in the justness of the
woman's cause according to him she
selectively targets those who inspired
the perpetrators of a devastating
tragedy locked in a battle of ideologies
Lockhart manages to escape from Rao's
clutches fueled by determination and a
deep Longing For answers he confronts
the enigmatic woman responsible for the
string of killings in a heart-stopping
moment she unveils her true identity as
Raya a revelation that sends shock waves
through Lockhart's very core Raya is not
only Amy's daughter but also Lockhart's
own granddaughter many years have passed
since the previous events and Lockhart
finds himself facing a Moment of Truth
deeply aware of the devastating
consequences triggered by the white
nationalist militia group's terrorism
which plunged the nation into a brutal
Civil War in 2024 when Raya was just a
young child of nine he makes a bold and
difficult decision Lockhart convinces
Raya now an adult to undertake a crucial
Mission a mission that involves
traveling backward in time appearing
every nine years in Reverse
chronological order raya's mission is to
inject her Targets in the back of their
necks with a specially designed isotope
from her perspective the events of 2006
have yet to unfold and her hand remains
unwounded it is a Race Against Time as
Raya Endeavors to prevent the future
tragedy that awaits as the weight of
guilt Bears heavily upon Him Lockhart
finally confesses a painful truth to
Raya he was the one who took her life in
1988. the Revelation is a
heart-wrenching moment as the
intertwined Destinies of grandfather and
granddaughter Collide however
understanding the justness of raya's
cause and the gravity of the situation
Lockhart comes to terms with his own
role in this complex tapestry in a
deeply meaningful and poignant act
Lockhart allows Raya to fulfill her
Mission knowing that it is necessary to
prevent the impending catastrophe with
her departure into the past an elderly
Rao steps forward triggering the
injections that bring about the deaths
of raya's targets as a result the
terrorist attack and the subsequent
Civil War are erased from the timeline
altering the course of history returning
to the year 2015 Lockhart finds solace
in reuniting with his family embracing
the opportunity for a fresh start he
Embraces the Newfound future with his
granddaughter Raya by his side it is a
moment of reconciliation hope and the
promise of a brighter tomorrow click on
one of the videos on your screen right
now